l'état grippal est un état infectueuses
obligatoirement liés au virus de la
grippe public et son approche par ces
symptômes fièvre élevée et maux de tête
courbatures et une appétence mal ça va
faire bien j'ai simplement une [ __ ] de
grippe mon pote ou devrais je dire j'ai
un sacré état grippal ça et que le
médecin qui dit ça je sors d'un tournage
de 30 minutes d'une vidéo qui ne sortira
jamais parce qu'elle est nul à chier
jamais une vidéo où je parlais aussi peu
c'était peut-être dix secondes de parole
par minute
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on va faire du
cumaj en profiter pour vous parler c'est
finalement fait qu'on s'amuse sur des
jaunards mais c'est bien aussi de se
parler comme ça sans je voulais vous
remercier parce que désolé je voulais
vous remercier pascal et vous avez adoré
les deux vidéos vous m'avez envoyé pas
mal de mettre des mails et mêmes les
commentaires j'ai vu que vous étiez
devant nombreux à dire qu'elle vous
plaisait plus que d'habitude et ça se
voyait même au niveau des poussières
j'ai même fait un petit truc pour vous
remercier c'était assez ou femmes rondes
avec séoul et pas à séoul d'instants
france n'était pas assez ou là encore et
abandonner malade mais on est toujours
là point jeu de mots de merde non sans
déconner ça m'a fait super chaud au
coeur
d'ailleurs j'ai eu une grippe
instantanément tellement ça me fait
plaisir en fait je prends beaucoup
beaucoup de plaisir à faire des vidéos
bien plus qu'avant déjà parce que
maintenant je bosse avec clément qui
cadre par exemple les vidéos htc va y va
on s'amuse beaucoup moi peut-être plus
que lui d'ailleurs je pense qu'ils
pensent qu est ce que je suis en train
de faire de même
c'est un peu triste d'être tout le temps
seul dans ce qu'on aime faire d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que maintenant j'ai un
studio que vous avez pu voir et non je
ne fais plus les vidéos de chez moi et
pourquoi s'agit en fait je pétait un
câble à rester chez moi toute la journée
et quand je bossais et quand je bossais
pas et quand jouer j'étais tout le temps
entre les mêmes murs et ça m'a rendu fou
alors bien le fait de me lever le matin
comme tout le monde
à 11 heures à youtube heures ces
chômeurs et je vois pas les usa comme un
truc désagréable au contraire c'est
super cool de ce lever de bouger de chez
soi mais d'aller dans un endroit qu'on
aime tout autant que chez soi pour y
faire un truc qu'on aime fin bref c'est
super je suis vraiment aux anges depuis
que j'ai ce petit studio enfin petit et
quand même grand j'ai de la chance voilà
du coup je le disais quoi ah oui
pourquoi vous trouviez les vidéos
meilleur qu'avant et ouais quand on est
super prend du plaisir à faire des
vidéos bas ça se voit et quand il en
prend moins ça se voit aussi et ça
m'arrivera sûrement d'en prendre moins
dans certaines vidéos que l'on doit bien
évidemment il deuxième truc si les
[ __ ] de commentaires au lala depuis
qu'il ya l'équipe de modération lac est
au taquet c'est fantastique je prends
trop de plaisir à les commentaires j'ai
vraiment l'impression de faire des
vidéos et que des gens l'air regarde et
pas défaire dans le vent en fait même si
a marqué à 1 ou 2 millions de vues c'est
énorme
astronomie comme chief c'est incroyable
mais tu te rends pas vraiment compte
alors que quand c'est des gens qui
écrivent des choses tu te rends plus
compte
du coup depuis que je lis les
commentaires et je vois vos phrases de
trucs marrants vos délires vos iphone ça
me fait vraiment plaisir voilà je vous
remercie pour cet espace commentaires
qui redevenu génial je remercie les gens
qui postent des commentaires vraiment
cool je remercie l'équipe de modération
et je remercie ceux qui m'avaient
prévenue de l'existence ce système de
modération des commentaires du tube
parce que [ __ ] je n'avais pas la
moindre idée
hier on se fait chier dessus sur un jeu
d'horreur aujourd'hui on se remercier
ses superbes hausses n'ont aucun sens
que je vais dire ensemble écouter
deuxième saut j'ai ouvert ma boutique le
tshirt ya à peu près un an je crois j'en
ai jamais reparlé depuis et vous savez
quoi
il ya des nouveautés comme par exemple
ce [ __ ] de pulls que je kiffe trop
portée c'était super super valls non
j'avoue j'ai déconné je suis le mec le
moins vendeur au monde j'ai oublié
d'amener les t-shirts et les pulls pour
vous montrer à part du coup je vous mets
des petites photos par ci par là
il ya notamment le pool stikeman que je
trouve vraiment cool il est aussi cool
que le style que j'ai actuellement
acheté le ceto qui vont devoir proposer
à des vêtements comme ça vous êtes pas
du tout que j'ai été acheté d'ailleurs
si vous n'avez pas acheté absolument pas
mais ça me fait plaisir de proposer ça à
ceux qui ont envie que ça existe et d'un
proposer des trucs un peu cool un peu
marrant un peu boya forcément le tee
shirt basique avec park et squeeze tu as
mais avec des gris un peu plus cool que
même moi je mets dans la vie de tous les
jours alors que m d'un tee shirt imac et
squeeze dessus certains osent pas et je
comprends tout à fait enfin bon voilà
n'hésitez pas à faire un tour dans la
boutique si vous voulez en plus est noël
et où là il ya là dessus d'un région est
une
et sinon vous allez aux haras en bas de
chez vous et c'est bien aussi et ben
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette petite
vidéo de type grippal
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à aller à la pharmacie
mon gars j'ai acheté la panoplie j'ai
pris les wheat pour le nez le str et
pour la gorge
le doliprane le sirop pour la toux sèche
le sirop pour la toux grasse le sirop
contre la touriste un touriste à eau
je suis désolé de vous importuner avec
ses blagues nulles mais vous me
pardonner parce que là je suis en
souffrance eh beh ouazine si j'avais à
dire oui un petit l'expliquent qui
arrivera dans deux semaines
premier épisode qui sortira le 5
décembre j'espère que ça vous plaira on
va faire une ambiance tamisée poser
qu'on a fait pour inside out is well
fait un vrai teaser ouais bah là on part
sur un gros buzz a encore plus que le
trailer de ghost in the shell
le 5 décembre
il revient pour un nouveau let's play
c'est tout pour nous c'est la petite
vidéo ambiance tamisée poser maladie
désolé pas avoir fait une vidéo un peu
plus marrante mais là j'avoue j'arrive
plus à infléchir ses shows que j'ai
carrément dû faire un mémo pour retenir
ce que j'avais à vous dire j'écris comme
un saut vers savoir regarder la vidéo
verser regarder toutes les vidéos en
général vous êtes vraiment géniaux ont
réalisé une prochaine vidéo je vous
remercie nouvelle fois merci merci merci
merci portez vous bien
couvrez vous bien il tente pas à l'état
grippal venez ont banni le mot grippe de
la langue française
on dit que état grippal manon à la drire
portez vous bien des gens du monde pis
elle est folle ambiance